[Music]
welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is cavae Madani who is currently at the
Macmillan Center as a Henry Hart Rice
senior fellow professor Madani is an
environmental scientist educator and
activist who works at the interface of
science policy and society he previously
served as deputy head of Iran's
Department of Environment and is known
for his role in raising public awareness
about water and environmental problems
there today we'll talk with Professor
Madani about environmental security in
the Middle East
welcome professor Madani thanks for
having me so you have been working in
the environmental arena for a while now
and I'm curious to know what drew you to
be interested in that I grew up in a
water family my parents worked for the
water secretary in Iran yeah I was the
only child they had no choice but taking
me two trips and missions and I grew up
learning about a lot of water problems
around the country lots of projects and
so on and that's what got me into the
water resources field got trained as an
engineer water resources engineer and
and over time I tried to pay attention
to some other dimensions of water
problems and and why with so much talent
in for example my home country and the
rest of the region so many
infrastructure in place and and so many
good projects still the region is
suffering from serious water and
environmental problems and and that was
the main motivation still trying to
figure out what's what's going on
right right so things in Iran are pretty
bad at this point with the scarcity of
water so let's let's not only talk about
around but also elsewhere in the Middle
East what is the actual situation
environmentally and
of water so when we talk about water in
the Middle East you know we always know
Middle East as a dry region so a lot of
oil a lot of gas but no much water and
and so so naturally this region of the
world is is having problems struggling
with with water now when you go from one
country to to another situation can be
different as we are speaking
today's people in north of Iran are
struggling with a heavy snowfall and
then you know a lot of people think that
that Middle East is is fully dry deserts
and camels know there is variability
there but but as you know when we look
at the region as a whole they don't get
as much precipitation as the rest of the
world and so they're shortened under
water water budget now as the rest of
the world they want to drink shower and
clean and run their industry and most
importantly grow food and drawn their
agriculture and this is the main main
problem of the Middle East that they
don't have enough water for producing
food based on their business as usual
plants they can do much better they can
do things much more efficiently if if
they reformed their plans and do a
better job so what we are seeing right
now today is declining aquifer levels
across the you know the region drawing
wetlands and and lakes and rivers
resulting in dust storms groundwater
drawdown is is resulting in land
subsidence sinkholes and a lot of
problems that we are seeing which some
of them are emerging and and new
actually an unprecedented in in the
Middle East and and causing a lot of
trouble I don't so so so like for
example dust on so parts of the region's
the region have had dust storms in the
past but right now we are seeing you
know shut down of cities because of dust
storms and when dust comes
I have experienced that when dust comes
it's not only that like you know you you
get problems with being outside and
cannot you know the the air in on those
issues we have had episodes where where
dust sits on for example electricity
grids then there is a blackout and as a
result of a blackout that water water
supply units stop working and water
treatment plants can't work so as a
result of a dust storm then you have no
water no no electricity no life in
cities and of course a lot of health
problems so this is just one example of
so many examples around the region where
people are heavily affected people lose
their jobs because of the lack of water
farmers have to migrate they move from
one location to another and most
importantly we see tensions and economic
suffering and a lot of conflicts between
inside inside the you know the countries
over over water transfer projects over
different dam building and reservoir
building projects and and so on so water
is kind of tied to the life of people
tied to the economy of the people and
that is why the situation is so so bad
right yeah you cannot have life without
water so it is something that I think
you know probably should be pretty
prevalent in most people's lives and
thinking about it and I am curious to
know if that is the truth are they aware
of the scarcity of water so so again I
think you know there's one thing called
scarcity the other thing is like you
know having a low budget my thinking is
that that the Middle East can do much
better with the available water they can
afford having a better economy work on
their use their water for the right
purpose the problem we have had in the
Middle East is in some of the countries
where we're having oil based economy so
so you you got a plenty of money to do
through you know you can earn plenty of
money through your natural resources by
selling your oil and gas then you you
have null hat
have not planned well for your your
agriculture and water sector essentially
heavy subsidies have been given to the
farmers to grow food and not not you
know good plans are not there then they
they always have had the fear for the
raipur I think for the right reasons
about food insecurity being independent
on other nations for for importing their
food so they have tried to grow this
this sector without good plans and and
without thinking that water can be a
limit to the growth as a result then we
are seeing farmers who are suffering
then we are saying that food security
plans are failing and and then
environmental damages are there people
though might not feel this scarcity if
you will or what I call a water
bankruptcy and it's simply a mismatch
between the available water and the use
because they get the to eat their food
they get their their water through their
taps and and and and they don't feel it
now in some parts of the region like
Jordan like policy the Palestinian
territories we are you know people are
suffering and they're seeing this impact
in some other places no because we
desalinate we move water we we transfer
water restore water we take water out of
the ground and they don't feel it and
part of the problem is is the fact that
I think not only the Middle Eastern
societies but also their politicians
have not yet believed you know found out
the fact or admitted this you know
wanted to accept this fact that that
that's a shortage to deal with and and
it's not how much money you have it's
not like how much how much
infrastructure and engineering talent
you have this problem needs to be dealt
with in a different in a different ok
and also I imagine tensions in the
region the Middle East region in general
and Wars also play into this of this
paradigm very good question because you
know then with what we have seen seen in
the recent years and over the reefs
especially the recent decade in the
Middle East our Western reading of the
case is I think very misleading what we
hear from the media and and some
analysts of the region is that for
example drought has caused or created
Isis or has caused all the problems in
in Syria or climate change has been the
cause of the Arab Spring and and and
things like that or for example in Iran
strikes and demonstrations have been
because of water or water shortage water
as well as other environmental problems
the problems are not limited to water
because in the Middle East we're dealing
with air pollution with deforestation
with with biodiversity losses with with
with waste with tons of environmental
problems you name it like whatever is
out there with you know unfortunately
the region is suffering from now yes
these problems can worsen the situation
of the people can result in job losses
can function as catalysts to tension but
the other side of this story that we
don't appreciate when it comes to the
Middle East as well as some parts of the
developing world is that Wars lack of
stability tensions conflicts sanctions
and all these together create a
situation where natural systems cannot
really fix their economy working on
their economy do a better job to
transfer the pressure from the
agricultural sector to other sectors so
when when a country goes through tension
then the it cannot really plan well for
for reforming its agricultural sector or
environmental sectors so the tensions in
the Middle East are causing
environmental degradation and this is
something we don't appreciate and we
don't talk about we are afraid of the
future of the region talking about what
can climate change do to the region and
how it can cause migration we don't talk
about how the core intention in the
region is causing environmental
degradation and the fact that if we want
to prevent more environmental damages we
need
more economic stability we need to you
know peace in the region and we need to
work on those issues as a pre-requisite
to what is happening and unfortunately
we are missing those components okay so
those are are pretty big things to work
on so if what else can be done what are
what are your thoughts on what else can
be done in order to to try and move
things in the right direction
essentially if if it's about like us
helping them or you know it's it's about
understanding the truth on the ground
it's you know it's it's understanding
that Middle Eastern leaders are not all
stupid farmers in the Middle East are
similar to farmers around the world they
they they work to earn money and they
produce food it's nothing is different
now it is easy to say that change your
economic you know make economic reforms
decouple your economy from oil the
couple your economy from from water but
but this transition path has to be
defined and it has to be enabled if we
want to want to prevent environmental
degradation in the Middle East then we
have to work on on building institutions
we have damaged the institution's the
social structures that have been formed
around natural resources we are talking
about civilizations which are a thousand
you know that you know for thousands of
years have functions all these
modernization
wars and tension and invasions and so on
have resulted in the destruction of
these institutions so now if we want to
prevent environmental degradation we
have to understand that it's you know
peace and bimanual sustainability
economic stability come together as a
package so you can no single out the
environmental sector and say go do this
for the environmental sector because if
you want to fix the environmental
problems you have to figure out you have
to realize that the root causes of the
environmental problems are normally out
of the environmental sector and if you
want to address those
have to work on other sectors we
understand how cap you know the the
capitalist system is affecting our
environmental sector so if you want to
solve the problems we cannot continue
with the current economic model that we
have the middle-east relies on water
land and other natural resources to
create jobs unemployment is something
that all governments around the world
including the government of the United
States is afraid are afraid of so so to
create jobs to keep people happy
to keep people silent and and to prevent
migration to to urban areas and to
prevent tension governments are willing
to bribe and spend their natural
resources for their citizens to the
citizens to prevent wars and conflicts
so in the short term you degrade the
environment because you want to help the
people and and keep your power in the
long run you create problems that in the
interconnected world have global
implications so if you understand the
global implications of the problems in
that particular region of the world we'd
better do our assignment in a better way
understand what is going on and
understand how our decisions can impact
them so understanding that is one thing
of course but the practicality of how do
you how do you turn that around so to if
you if you want to turn that around you
understand that you know you you pay to
the route pay attention to the root
causes unfortunately we don't do that we
we saw we saw terrorism and then we made
a country we attack a country and try to
solve that problem then we make a
country more unstable then there is
environmental degradation if you
understand that extremism is because of
being poor is because of lack of
education is because of lack of jobs and
so on then you realize that maybe to
prevent terrorism maybe to prevent these
sorts of conflicts to avoid future
problems then you need to invest in
education in creating jobs in helping
these economies flourish and do a better
job and change their path so this is
oral now it's also the governments of
the region having roles it's it's not
the responsibility of the United
States or Europe to help the countries
in the regions the the region we have to
also remind those countries about the
mistakes that we have made on this part
of the world I always say that you know
California is a perfect example for the
middle-eastern to learn from Middle
Easterners to learn from because in
California we have done a lot of good
jobs but we have made a lot of mistakes
as well and and the the developing world
can learn from those mistakes and avoid
them and we have to highlight those and
talk about those and tell them how we
can you know why providing water is one
thing and controlling the man is another
thing providing water and building dams
and digging deeper and and building
desalination plants and recycling and
reuse is one thing having plans for your
economic sector having plans for your
industrial sector is another thing so so
so the governments of the region also
need to understand that this is not a
sustainable model and and the fact that
you cannot make sectors secure
separately the governments of the region
have focused on making their environment
their food system secure right I don't
want to be dependent on the rest of the
world I produce oil I want the rest of
the world to be dependent on my oil but
I don't want my food to be dependent on
the rest you know the rest of the world
why because then when it comes to the
time of sanctions changing the oil
prices then I just my situation so then
you want to make your food system secure
then you create water insecurity
problems human insecurity problems so we
have to understand that we live in an
interconnected world we are dealing with
wicked problems but there are lots of
trade-offs and uncertainties that we
need to deal with and if you try to
solve the problems within small sectors
then we create unintended consequences
as we have seen in the region we want to
build the dam to help the people then we
create environmental damages we want to
transfer water to for agriculture then
we dry up a lake and cause dust storms
we want to you know build a city which
is one of the best cities in the world
and and you know a big capital and put
an airport there and you know bring a
lot of people or tourists and or so on
then we create waste issues and air
pollution issues and
traffic issues and so on because we
don't understand that everything is
connected and the root causes and the
solutions of the environmental sector in
many cases are out of the my muddled
sector so environmental experts on their
own water experts on their own water
managers and and environmental managers
on their own would not be able to solve
their problems and address their
problems the economy of the Middle East
there am a lot of model of development
need to change and they have to
understand that the the the model that
they have adopted the dreams of of you
know build the dreams of competing with
the older you know United States model
to have the tallest biggest and the
largest buildings malls and so on would
not give their people the stability they
deserve and their environment would not
be sustainable under the current
circumstances and according to the
current plans so what do you with that
said what do you think the future holds
for the Middle East so I think we would
have the issue of the limit the growth
problem so we do not unfortunately
proactively avoid problems I've been on
governments and you know on the
government I know how government's
functions functions governments function
I know that for a government which is
four years in office no matter where in
the world the problems that are urgent
are more important and and when I have
problems like unemployment wars with
with with with other countries in the
region's war with with the Western
powers and lots of other things
environment is just luxury problem to
deal with later on so I know that I
think that we would not see that that
governments in the region proactively
address their environmental problems
what we see is that limited growth we've
create a problem then we put a bandaid
on it we go to the next problem to the
next problem to the next problem and
it's it's just learning by doing and and
once you know addressing problems after
failing that is why that it this is this
is maybe a paradox but but I pre I
appreciate
some of the natural crises and extreme
events that appear in under the radar of
of the politicians because once they see
a place under fire once they see a real
problem once they see a place flooded
once they see a big drought then there
is a window of opportunity to take
actions look at California and what how
how much they accomplished during five
years of drought and and look at South
Africa and what they accomplished during
their you know when they got close to
their day zero the same applies to the
Middle East you can we can talk about
climate change forever
well while people might not realize it
by the fire a flawed a big snowfall you
know snowstorm and and lots of extreme
events help him realize unfortunately
the cost of this is huge and and relying
on nature to teach us lessons can be
very costly because people can die
people can lose law lives and jobs and
and in the economic damage and death
toll can be huge but unfortunately this
is the model that we go with what we can
do though is to put that information out
there to come up with right the right
narratives about the middle eastern
environmental problems I strongly
believe that the middle eastern
environmental security problems have
been misunderstood the the scientists
have not done a good job about it we
simply overlooked it that the regional
governments have not looked at it and
the intelligence and security and
military community have also
misunderstood it even today the view of
environmental security problems the
perspective is very I would say you know
we look at those problems with the
military lens with with it it with any
you know security lens in a very
traditional form we don't understand the
interconnectedness we we understand the
the connection of environmental
degradation to human security well we
don't pay attention to the environmental
degradation problem I'm sorry - the
human societal degradation problem on
the environmental security this we're
dealing with a reinforcing loop
a feedback loop which is very
frustrating and and if you don't
understand these situations if you put
out reports if you rely on the media
headlines which we try to climate eyes
every event in the reach and which try
to blame everything on Natural Resources
not the governments of the region which
try to to to exaggerate about some
problems and and then you know this
misinformation and narratives not only
confuses us but also the region and the
people in the region who don't know what
what to do so we need to do our science
better at least as a scientist at a
university this is what I can do also go
out and talk about it speak about these
problems and inform the rest of the
world so the message really needs to be
a little bit more straightforward than
it has been I think we first need to
understand you know put the facts
together and understand what is going on
we need to understand that yes climate
change is a big threat and as a person
who has been involved in in working on
climate change I want the the the
leaders in the region to pay attention
as much as I want the leaders in the
United States to pay attention to it but
we also need to understand the the human
dimension of the problem the
anthropogenic impacts at the local level
created by governments created by
development plans and and and the lack
of foresight into the future we have to
get the narrative right first based on
scientific facts not the jargon that we
hear and and then once we have a solid
base for our analysis go out and come up
with it right narrative speak about it
take it to the International and
intergovernmental agencies take it to to
media and and then take a proper
decision which not only help that part
of the world helps that part of the
world but also the rest of the world
because in this interconnected world the
more environmental problems don't
recognize our geographical boundaries
and political boundaries they travel
across regions and generations the the
future generations in the region would
suffer from what has happened in recent
years from the
farmers who have left their their lands
because of war and couldn't form and now
they you know their lands as a source of
dust storms and then because of the all
the degradation because of air pollution
because of increasing you know health
risks and health problems in in the
region we have to understand that these
things can be transferable and
transferred as we were talking and
speaking we're dealing with one problem
in China
Crona wires and we have no probably no
analysis whatsoever and we had no
expectation of something with this
magnitude interrupting the whole world
the economic you know flows between the
countries now countries having problems
selling their oil to to China and now
farmers in the neighboring countries
having problems selling their watermelon
to China so people are losing jobs
economies are suffering because of an
outbreak of a disease in some part of
the world if we understand and
appreciate this interconnectedness a lot
of our approaches would be different and
if we understand that at the end of the
day we are after human security and no
system can be secured without securing
and paying attention to the balance
between environmental sector economic
sector social sector political sector
education health etc then we won't put a
military lens on you know on for every
problem and and we treat some problems
differently it's not all about how much
you know you know it doesn't matter how
many missiles the Iranians have it
doesn't matter how many true how many
soldiers the Americans have in the
region if the environment is not there
if there is no water if people cannot
you know live live there it doesn't
matter who runs the system and how how
much in love the governments of that
region are with the government of the
United States or the rest of the world
we have to understand these realities
that we don't pay attention to but all
the time we are we are talking about
governments which are in in office for a
short for sure for a short period of
time and don't
about the future they think about what
keeps them in power and what gets them
real active and that's the problem
basically the clock is ticking I feel
and I think you know change needs to
happen sooner rather than later only in
foreign societies I think can identify
their problems correctly and and and and
select leaders who would address their
their problems when when the leader you
know to have people in a society which
cares about the environment you need
leaders who care about the environment
to educate them and to have leaders who
care about the environment you need a
society which cares about the
environment and select those who care
you know select leaders who would
address those problems now this is a
chicken and egg problem what we can do
about this is to inform them and
understand that it that even in
dictatorships even in dictatorships what
the alternative narratives are blocked
and and you don't want the societies to
go with any other scenario or believe
any other narrative you can make a
change
once the society you know challenges its
its government challenges it's its
leaders about problems and we have seen
this we have seen a growing attention to
environmental problems in the region a
growing attention of the leaders also
and actually a growing frustration of
the leaders who now think that maybe
environment is another sector that can
be used in wars in it can be used for
political purposes and so on we have
seen the crackdown of the
environmentalists in in a in a group of
environmentalists in Iran we are seeing
other things similar examples in other
parts of the region I know people in
Iraq who have got into trouble I know
people in Egypt who have been criticized
for doing what work on environmental
matters and the same is is true about
the region Israel also when it comes to
Israel a lot of problems are not really
well reflected in the international
media when it comes to water and
environmental problems the same is true
about the rest of the region we focus
and single out some of some some
countries
talk about those and some other
countries get away with with with their
you know problems and what they're doing
so this is what we need to change
information education and and believe a
strong belief in the fact that an
informed society an educated society and
an empowered society would have
different desired priorities and
requests and the government's need to
respond no matter how long they have
been in power no matter how dictator I
mean how much of a dictatorship they're
well hopefully that will come as I said
sooner rather than later
thank you so much for being here and
sharing some of your insights with us
thanks for having me thank you
for more information about Professor
Madani and his work please visit our
website at macmillan report yelled at
edu be sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale
you